we also have an eye to breaking news um
on another story we're following an
iranian scientist in prison in the u.s
is on his way back home zane basravi
joins us live now with more on that from
the phone
on the phone rather from tehran's
hussein what do you know about this
well rachelle we know that this morning
uh the foreign minister javad zarif sent
out a message on his instagram account
saying hello friends good news
a plane carrying doctor sudos gary flew
from the united states and he sent the
congratulations to mr esquiri's wife and
family now serious escari
was on trial in a federal court in ohio
his trial started in 2018.
he was acquitted last month of charges
of
wire fraud visa fraud and as well as
stealing trade secrets mr azgary was a
material sciences professor
he had a position at sharif university
here in iran
and as many things happen in between the
united states and iran he's become a bit
of a playing card in a broader
political game from the united states
there were frustrations from officials
there about
iran not arranging or making the
arrangements for the return of
asgary as well as other iranian citizens
that the united states said they wanted
to return
and iran has been criticizing officials
over and over again
uh over the last few weeks and months
have been criticizing the united states
for not making a speedy return of its
citizens
there's at least 20 or so uh iranians
thought to be
held in the united states mr oscar is
one of them there are five americans
being held in iranian custody one of the
most high profile of them is a navy
veteran named
mark white who was arrested last year
for visiting masha he was
reported to have been visiting a woman
with whom he was in a romantic
relationship and was arrested
and detained he's currently in swiss
custody uh he was released
for the sake of trying to protect him
from the spread of kogit 19
in the prison systems now there's been a
lot of speculation as to whether or not
any of the prisoners being held in iran
will be released
uh as mr oscar is on a plane making his
way home
but the fact of the matter is is that
many people are also saying that mr
oscar's release is a is
basically a function of the u.s court
system not necessarily something that
would lead to any kind of prisoner swap
but nonetheless there is speculation
here that this could result
in some kind of exchange of citizens and
the
iranian government here will no doubt be
using mr oscar's return
as an opportunity to gain some positive
publicity
okay sam vasravi with the latest there
from tehran zane thank you